[Music]
you much of a drinker jason
sometimes drink a little bit not a lot
what's your go-to drink um probably
jamison pretty basic
that's it or tequila jameson's very
asian huh
hennessey is very asian oh yeah
hennessey's variations hennessey's
vietnamese
yeah alcoholicism is uh asian yeah it's
very asian we're just
alcoholism is uh
multicultural i think everyone i think
everyone indulges everyone likes
hennessy i think no ethnic biases when
it comes to alcohol you ever had a henny
chatta you know what i mean a horchata
with honey no yeah but that sounds good
it's quite good i don't i'm not a
drinker but i had someone i was like
this is i see why people like this what
about your thoughts on
jagermeister i've never had it um i
think you showed us a clip
or a story which is what we're gonna
talk about right now so i'm not gonna
say it i'm not gonna spoil it dude
jagermeister actually i i remember
drinking it a lot when i was young they
remember in uh at bars they would always
have those mini jagermeister like uh
cooler taps or drafts right they had a
separate machine that had the
jagermeister logo on it they would take
a bottle put it on top like it's a spout
like a draft and then it would cool the
[ __ ] jager like ice cold cool and you
put it in a [ __ ] shot glass and that
would be a huge thing yeah people used
to drink jager bombs all the time too
yeah
which is still gross to this day why
it's red bull and jagermeister but that
is if i drink it now i'm like that's
gross but we used to drink it all the
time i actually used to help me because
you know alcohol makes me like sleepy
but then the red bull like gets you up
does jager taste like black licorice is
that it does no it tastes like cough
syrup so here's a noob question how is
jagermeister really strong it's like
your regular alcohol in in any
circumstance but it's kind of thick and
almost like uh like licorice chocolatey
so sometimes it's uh
easier to consume quickly and i think
the culture of jaeger when people drink
jaeger you don't like drink to die yeah
dude they drink to die you know what i'm
saying it's it's different when you
usually yeah you're like i'm gonna get
[ __ ] up tonight i feel like jaeger's a
tough guy drink like like all like
strong guys drink it but it tastes so
fruity for something so tough i feel
like it's for [ __ ] no really i don't
know i'm not a big drinker i don't know
speaking of tough tough [ __ ] um
yeah that that article i texted you guys
that says a man dies after downing a
whole bottle of jagermeister in two
minutes you know what i've seen so many
viral videos of people doing i don't
know if it's real or fake where they
drink a whole like yeah bottle of
alcohol and i'm surprised it doesn't
happen more often because that was like
a trend for a while where people put a
straw in it and they try to chug like
whatever miscellaneous alcohol yeah you
should die right yeah you can't get
alcohol alcohol poisoning and if you get
saved to the point where like the emts
make you yeah they pump you and [ __ ]
like that then you can survive tell you
about a time that i almost killed a
person because i didn't know
but like so when we were touring with
lmfao we do these things where we bring
people up from the audience and we do
like a beer funnel
right you almost killed somebody in
front of thousands at a concert your
your game is [ __ ] hella heavy
because i don't i've never drank alcohol
in my life i don't know the differences
between alcohols right so
i'm never usually the funnel guy i don't
administer the beer this time you're the
one with that yeah this time i'm the
funnel guy and this like girl comes on
stage and then i just grabbed whatever
alcohol was there
i poured a patron bottle into the funnel
oh my god and she downed this whole like
funnelized i didn't know when i was
putting as much as i saw the other guys
do it with beer
so the whole bottle
oh well it wasn't full but a lot of it
and she didn't know what what she kept
going and she just kept going oh my god
and then i said on stage she goes
it just goes
holy [ __ ] just immediately falls
and in this whole time it's i'm sexy
and then the girl is just [ __ ] on the
ground
she's like throwing up and then the
other guys are they grab me they're like
you're gonna kill someone and i was like
why what's the difference
i had no idea like the difference
between patronus what happened to her
what happened to her she was just
knocked out she i don't think she
tried to wake her up or like just like
kind of rolled off the stage oh my gosh
and nobody's ever heard of her since
i mean that's that's one of them
but yeah ryan's like they didn't stop me
until 13 of these happened
yeah usually at the 13th i wish she
remembered which song at that moment was
she rolling he's trying to party to the
right song right now he's been trying to
break out in the song he usually is sexy
noise
i'm sexy or not but then there were
people that were drinking that much
voluntarily on their own yeah and i was
just like in my head i just was like so
amazed to see that [ __ ] people would be
passing out all the time you were always
sober during all those events well
because you don't do anything right yeah
are you sober now
yeah
yeah i'm straight edge i was at rosarito
i saw [ __ ] the game chug a whole
bottle of grey goose the game no it
could have been water too i don't know
probably mix it probably mix it for sure
because a whole bottle like when you saw
him in person do this
i mean he was like really far away on a
concert stage dude you're really
connected to the game like you have a
lot of you have multiple stories about
the game
remember you hit him up about a verse
and he was like yo how much
he's like how long the track is
how many bars and you see him chugging
[ __ ] alcohol like you just randomly
bring him up that's true that's true my
friend put him in uh jk shirts yeah
exactly and then this guy's a story
about the game too
yeah he does the jewelry right he was
making um he was he used to be his
personal like cook and trainer
so they used to make food and he's like
hey my friends got these shirts put it
on and then so he put it on and they're
like hiking or something and they all
took pictures together you're the [ __ ]
power pesos shirt on
why does that sound so weird yeah it's
random it's so random because it's the
game dude normalized weird
so this uh this dude is from south
africa actually uh he was taking part in
a drinking competition in an area called
limpopo oh it was during a comp yeah
when he consumed v to answer your
question 35 spirit so i think a lot of
the alcohols we normally drink hard
liquors like 40 80 proof this one's 35
so it's actually a little bit weaker
so it's easier probably to consume a lot
so it is for [ __ ] like you said
this is in africa south africa yeah so
uh i believe the man who is believed to
be 20 between 25 and 30 years old
immediately collapsed that sucks at us
during a contest and was rushed to a
nearby hospital where he was pronounced
dead oh my god dude if it's for a
contest like
what the [ __ ] like don't they know that
that's gonna kill someone eventually
like so
the prize for the the cash prize that
was offered i don't know the currency it
says r200 but it's approximately about
like 10 pounds of money so like
literally if you were to win this
alcohol drinking competition you'd win
like less than 15 bucks but that's a lot
though
for them
uh well again i i don't know the
currency uh
exchange or anything let me look that up
real quick that's crazy one one of my
buddies used to down a bottle of
jagermeister all the time what yeah him
and his buddy they would uh him and his
twin brother actually they would down it
and then they'd put on [ __ ] knights
of armor and reenact what sucks with
each other renaissance [ __ ] fights
yeah that's different though right if
you're maybe also you know how like uh
when you drink a lot of alcohol in like
college or something like that right
next thing you know you're talking about
like oh i took like 18 shots this day
about bob because you've also kind of
like conditioned and trained your liver
yeah i can imagine somebody's going in
for the first time maybe or doesn't
normally do this type of thing so what
are the things um anatomically that help
tolerance to alcohol
like it's being fat
i remember when you uh in college when i
knew we were gonna get like really
really like go hard that night because
you know when you drink in college you
drink like for stupid reasons and people
be like we're gonna get [ __ ] up
tonight so i'd always like eat hella
bread before we partied so is that
because it absorbs yeah
that's what people would say right you
just eat a bunch of like carbs or
mcdonald's you grab like a burger and
you just want like thick bread and oily
greasy type of no empty stomach yeah it
doesn't just hit you yeah yeah because
i've done that a couple of times and
your boy got a [ __ ] would it would a
certain type of person have an advantage
if they were just like bigger like a fat
[ __ ]
yeah they could probably consume more
right a lot of bigger dudes would always
be able to drink a lot more i'm guessing
when you were younger you might have
been able to drink a little bit more
than you do now i don't know i was
stupid too i had low tolerance now i
just try to drink like everyone else and
i'll just puke every night like
literally [ __ ] puke all the [ __ ]
time
this guy's dedicated bro i'm trying to
hang out with people that was how it was
that was the culture yeah i just keep
puking yeah that's how i was you would
do whatever everybody said you just keep
drinking even though you passed your
limit and then eventually one day it
became your limit none of you guys have
ever been hospitalized from drinking too
much no but i [ __ ] puked all over the
ground and pissed in the trash can and
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my pillow in
front of my mom
the [ __ ]
that's probably worse i would rather be
hospitalized and then she threw me in
the shower and [ __ ] had to rinse me
off
because i had vomiting
yeah i was so [ __ ] up dude i was
drinking in my garage dive into the
details of [ __ ] a pillow did she tell
you do you remember anything or was it
your mom telling you everything i had no
snippets of it and she kind of told me
in the morning and then when i woke up
with the pillow no you were [ __ ] the
pillow and then you flipped it over is
it doggy yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] you get this one and then you just
did this one
and then you keep saying a bad girl
that's the worst you ever got drunk that
was the that was one of the worst
it's got to be one of the worst
like that shouldn't be a regular but you
know what i bet joe's mom was like
that's my joke she woke up when i woke
up in the morning and then like i was
like sleeping on the pillow and then
from that point on she always called my
pillow my girlfriend
[Laughter]
she's a [ __ ] rose queen bro yeah
yeah
your mom does good groundwork man he's
just teasing you yeah like she'll be
like you need to go to sleep with your
girlfriend
and then shuts the door yeah yeah leave
some condoms on the
[ __ ] that's her closer for her type
five
the first time ever i ever drank was
because of my dad
i was 15 and i was at home and just out
of nowhere he came up to me with like a
budweiser and he goes it's time whoa and
i was like what are you doing right i'm
like
you're 15. you're 15. you need to drink
this i'm like the whole thing goes yeah
the whole thing yeah you will put it and
i drink it i just remember having a
boner and the bucket is laid though
because i think just like the
circulation
because like what happened to you guys
because i get all flushed right i get
all flushed
i'm trying to think about the moment
your dad's coming downstairs it's like
it's time i'm going to make a man out of
this guy
gives him a whole beard gets a bone he's
like [ __ ] i don't know how to respond to
this bart's top 10 memorable bonus
that's number one dude
so when you when you drink you get red i
get red i get flushed like i got my
circle that's like me crazy that's like
your bonus
that's like a bonus
what was it that you drink just
budweiser it's like whatever whatever my
dad
whatever my dad had in the fridge it
just came like i gave you a blue pill
dude he put viagra in the [ __ ] bud
he's like he thinks it's gonna be so
funny he's always heard of that i didn't
know that's like that's legit getting a
boner yes i've always heard of boners
someday i'd like to experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you